we already know that Vladimir Putin I
call him Vlad but some people call blad
amir putin he's considered a strong
critic of nato really he considers nato
to be a threat to Russia and Putin's
admirer donald trump has also expressed
his fair share of nato criticisms in the
past even once calling it obsolete but
most recently at his speech in front of
a joint session of congress said
something like you know we we were part
of nato something pseudo positive about
nato we also know that trump's Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson is a longtime
friend and Russia involved guy well
there's a NATO meeting next month in
Brussels among the foreign ministers of
each member nation and our Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson who would be the
person that we would send to this
meeting the top diplomat of the trump
administration has said initially I'll
have the latest news in a second
initially that he is going to skip the
meeting where was he going to go instead
just a week later you guessed it not
Argentina to Russia congressman eliot
engel from new york the most senior
Democrat on the House Foreign Affairs
Committee said quote Donald Trump's
administration is making a grave error
that will shake the confidence of
America's most important alliance and
feed the concern that this
administration simply is too cozy with
Vladimir Putin I cannot fathom why the
administration would pursue this course
except a single signal a change in
American foreign policy that draws our
country away from Western democracies
most important institutions and aligns
the United States more closely with the
autocratic regime in the Kremlin the
u.s. is the most powerful and
influential member of the NATO alliance
we are the de facto leaders of NATO the
head of state the head of the State
Department should be at this meeting
this clearly has to be making our NATO
allies uneasy considering that Russia is
a photo NATO and Trump has over time
spoke negatively about the institution
and Tillerson in his earliest dealings
with other countries has been choosing
to turn his back on the smaller European
countries who have been our allies for
decades and who rely for us rely on us
for security in many cases and instead
is having bilateral meetings with major
world party
powers that we don't have military
accords with and in this case it happens
to be none other than Russia how would
you interpret this if you were one of
our NATO allies in terms of the American
commitment to this important alliance
even the former US ambassador to Russia
denounced this on Twitter Michael McFaul
saying this is fake news right
skipping NATO meeting to go to Moscow
that can't be true this is only going to
reinforce people's suspicions about
Russia and Trump and of course there has
been huge blow back to this and NATO
official speaking anonymously said hey
you know we offer to change the dates of
the meeting in order to make it easier
for Rex Tillerson to show up this is how
important it is most recently after the
backlash yesterday came to light that
now the US State Department is
reconsidering Rex Tillerson attendance
he'll probably end up going at this
point I would hope so I mean how
disrespectful is that I mean everyone
else seems to be going out of their way
bending over backwards right make this
happen and it seems like something else
to you is more important when Trump said
after months of negative comments about
NATO when he said at his speech his non
State of the Union State of the Union
that he's committed to the alliance with
NATO or whatever did you believe it or
did it strike he was just being optics
to get something on the record
that's not anti NATO he said everything
on the topic of NATO he said they're
obsolete he said that the u.s. stands
fully behind them I mean he covers the
whole spectrum on NATO just as he does
with any other issue so you just think
he was he was checking every box so that
at some point if he's questioned he can
say hey I did say X on Y date that's his
strategy yeah if it works for him it
kind of works pretty well because no
matter what your position is you can at
some point find a statement from Trump
where he seems to sort of agree with
your position